tension and a mounting police presence
on a South London estate but this isn't
a response to a criminal threat on the
other side of this human barricade is a
mother battling to save her home Ammon
Arthur lives here with her three
children and her elderly disabled mother
her local authority says she's built up
substantial rent arrears soon she could
be on the streets
I don't used to be poor and that's why I
don't wanted to choose what she meant to
be poor that's what I'm fighting people
this house is kind of like people don't
even believe that people live here okay
people think that this house is empty
even people come to up to discuss then
they use it solid they use poo on the
stairs you know just like any a bundle
as bailiffs arrived to evict Aminata
protesters have gathered at her flat
hanging banners in protest but what they
call social cleansing this is the
frontline of resistance against the
housing crisis housing provided by
social services we know that someone had
rats in there and we met other families
in fact the private sector who had
bedbugs like unsafe kind of electrical
wires and severe overcrowding the
intense pressure on council housing and
the unaffordability of the private
rental sector is pushing them to the
brink of homelessness even those that
are fortunate enough to be in temporary
accommodation like this block where
Aminata lives behind me is unfit for
habitation now a report presented to the
UN has found that that lack of quality
affordable housing and the resulting
increase in homelessness amounts to a
violation of human rights since last
year the number of households in
temporary accommodation in England has
increased by 11 percent bringing the
total to 64 thousand seven hundred and
ten households the total number of
households at risk of homelessness is
280,000 while those sleeping rough have
increased by 55 percent since 2010 and
14 percent in the last year and for
those in privately rented homes 29
percent of dwellings on non decent and
don't meet basic standards of health
the government housing bill published
this week isn't easing concerns it
proposes extending the right to buy and
requiring local authorities to sell more
of their existing properties on the
surface you can use the discounts and
the sale of the cost of the house to
build a new home and you can also
support homeownership in doing so in
reality on the current government plans
we're likely to see fewer and fewer
social homes as a result and this is not
what the policy should be doing the
government says their strategy is the
right one and that it's investing 1
billion pounds in preventing
homelessness that won't help Aminata
her eviction has been postponed for now
but it's only a matter of time before
the bailiffs return halfway her shinies